dal mio compleanno che si è festeggiato
ieri sera al karaoke ragazzi di
Chinatown di Milano vi lascio un paio di
clip Giusto per capire il disagio sì
io ti do due belle gnocche in cambio di
Slime
Luì
[Musica]
la sera dal cielo qui dentro bastassero
salvezza e tra tutti i regali che dicevo
poi ho ricevuto un sacco di regali
Quindi i miei amici sono meravigliosi ma
il regalo migliore me l'hanno fatto
Giampiero e Giuseppe regalo è questo qua
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Grazie Jean Giuseppe sono gli amici
Grazie ragazzi mi vedete dallo schermo
sfocatissimo Raga ma stiamo imbarcando
in questo momento io ogni viaggio che
faccio Spero sempre che non mi si sia da
nessuno di fianco così e come viaggiare
in business ma senza la business per
altri consigli Seguitemi Ragazzi scusate
ma ho notato Un'ultima cosa che prima di
scendere dall'aereo dovevo farvi vedere
tanto siamo molto vicini a Tokyo se
andiamo su le cose attivabili C'è un
tasto per la Mecca
vorrei anche il tasto per la Mac
[Musica]
la faccia di uno che ce l'ha fatta a
sopravvivere 12 ore di volo senza fare
la cacca perché non l'ho fatta Fatemi
sto cagando addosso ma qua hanno i cessi
riscaldatevi Non vedo l'ora di arrivare
in albergo Mamma mia non mi sembra vero
raga mi sento come la prima volta che
sono venuto io ogni volta che vengo qua
eh Mi sento come se fosse la prima volta
ogni giorno
[Musica]
e c'è anche una giornata della Madonna
ma neanche a farlo apposta Ragazzi mi
sono imbacuccato per amalgamarmi e
questo è il nostro magico Hotel mitsu
Garden Come non detto ragazzi ho
sbagliato albergo mi hanno respinto Sono
proprio un [__] non mi ricordavo ma
questo è l'albergo che avevo prenotato
dopo quando arriveranno i Pantellas
prima i tre giorni che rimango da solo
qua in Giappone io ho prenotato in un
altro albergo che è fortunatamente a 300
metri da questo quindi culo incredibile
Eccolo qua quello mio piccolino
piccolino ma caratteristico
perché mi hanno detto che la stanza non
era pronta per poi dirmi che volta dopo
se mi cresce ancora un po' di più la
barba e sembra un Keanu Reeves Day wish
Però allora ragazzi Ho schiacciato il
tasto r perché pensavo fosse tipo
reception invece kovatz è rotto quindi
ho sbagliato però vediamo com'è il rutto
Digital albergo già che ci siamo nello
sbaglio magari vediamo se ha fatto una
cagata con meno a parte il fatto che non
c'è nessuno è la cosa mi piace Madonna
ma Ragazzi ma è incredibile ma che
storia ma sto male sto male sto male
raga porca
porcato Eccoci qua bene Ciao Milano No
bellissimo ragazzi è un hotel stra
piccolo cioè letteralmente il letto è
incazzato dentro la stanza ragazzi è
veramente la mia valigia si è suicidata
dal chilometri che abbiamo fatto mi
occupo tutta la stanza Ok benissimo e
qua devo spazzare di lato
perché sennò non ci passo però è figo
cioè nel senso è comodo e ci devo stare
per tre giorni qua vediamo il bagno
ragazzi perfetto il bagno è finito pare
che non è ma è una è una micro stanza ma
c'ha tutto ciò che è un bel figo vi devo
dire vi devo dire E comunque prima di
travaccarmi sul letto e morire Vi faccio
notare la Chicca number one della stanza
che il televisore Luca Sono uscito a
vagare ad katsum e sono entrato in un
parco Random ma proprio Random Cioè non
gli avrei dato mezzo euro cioè Vabbè
vado nel primo parco che trovo È
incredibile va bene Vedo che fanno dei
pancake particolari perché sennò non ti
disturbo a tutti
gli occhiali non
sms carica
Tore Ok ragazzi la merenda l'abbiamo
fatta l'ho fatta lì c'è questa
Collinetta qua vicino e ti fa vedere
praticamente tutto il parco perché poi
tra l'altro è bellissima sembra fatta su
Animal Crossing sta facendo incredibile
e si può vedere tutto il parco veramente
figo Tra l'altro là ci sono gli alberi
di ciliegio che sono fioriti e se non lo
sapete ripetere di ciliegio cadono a 5
cm
al secondo perché ce l'ho anche io
Netflix Sì ce l'ho anch'io Madonna raga
in Giappone veramente Mi ha sempre
affascinato Cioè sta tecnologia delle
piante che hanno le casse integrate Ah
regà Ma ci hanno copiato il bosco
verticale Ragazzi quando Giampiero mi
chiede se ce ne andiamo in vacanza
insieme Però mi chiede dove andare in
vacanza la mia risposta
Ma quindi eri serio raga son tornato in
hotel sono uscito non c'è nessuno
cazzo è Elisi in borderland Oh la
Bonjour Madonna ho dormito tantissimo
ragazzi ben quattro ore giorno sono
sceso proprio l'altro c'è ma mi rendete
conto di che hotel Incredibile ho
trovato a €40 a notte carinissimo è qua
questa cosa non esiste Comunque siccome
quando sono in Giappone tendo a visitare
solo posti giapponesi Eccoci qua allora
robot Queste sono le macchine che
distribuiscono le macchinette
distribuiscono appunto le varie bibite
ce ne sono miliardi sparse per tutta
Tokyo E questa la simpatica tessera col
pinguino non so se ve la ricordate e la
tessera che si utilizza per comprare le
cose dalle macchinette per andare in
metro questa tessera ce l'ho dal 2016
dall'ultima volta che sono andato in
Giappone praticamente l'ho sempre tenuta
nel portafoglio e se tu la beggi qua ti
fa vedere quanto ti è rimasto sul conto
della carta Io non mi ricordo quanto era
rimasto era l'ultima volta che l'ho
utilizzata quindi vediamo un attimo che
esce fuori
nu cazz si passa che non mi ricordo
attenzione vediamo
ma non lo vedete bene perché flickera
però 755 yen sono tipo 5 euro cioè io ho
€5 in questa carta da 2016 praticamente
incredibile Vabbè che prendiamo la soda
di Clapis fantastico Terlizzi ci sono
gli elettroliti voglio questa bibita gli
elettroliti si può Ecco qua per Ice
Professional ragazzi facciamo un test
Che merda anche oggi ragazzi per
ingannare l'attesa che arrivano i
ragazzi Domani vi faccio dei giri senza
troppe pretese e sono in un parco che è
stato strabotato a livello di recensioni
si chiama parco Italia Anzi porco Italia
si nota dalle Colonne romane amabilmente
È incredibile no vabbè
sto male Cazzo ma questi sono i cosi che
il Resident Evil ti sbloccano le porte
sto scherzando comune di Pietrasanta
cioè Guardate che Mood 'sto signore che
Mood questo è surri ha 70 anni
praticamente credo anche oggi Favij vi
guida turistica ha fatto il suo ma la
cosa che amo di più del Giappone in
assoluto sono Sì passaggi sopraelevati
che non sono tipo dei ponti ma proprio
tipo come se ci facessero un parchetto
sopraelevato cioè completamente Se
qualcuno mi spiega che cos'è questa roba
gli regalo il canale sto scherzando
ragazzi non si può neanche scherzare
oggi eh Ah ecco qua ci sono gli orari di
quando entra in funzione quest'affare
non posso prendere e portarlo nel mio
salotto tipo perché è bellissimo Madonna
mi dà delle Siberia vice che non avete
idea Benvenuto buco di No Meno male che
sono femmina ragazzi Io non vorrei dire
non so che è mancata Aspetta mi avvicino
incredibile Eccoci qui
pazzesco vabbè no era abbastanza
sapevamo di essere a Tokyo tutti e due
ma non c'eravamo ancora scritti e non
c'è bisogno di scriverci si becca cazzo
sono dov'è che siamo qua siamo a koto
Booking e lui fa lo youtuber e secondo
voi quale sarà la prima esperienza che
faremo insieme in quel di Tokyo
transizione Questo è il menù Eccoci qua
perfetto
Eccoci si paga per avere la foto della
mail perché si chiama Maria con la e con
la e meria però non è che ci fa una foto
con lei quella da sua foto
con lei quanto costa te €15 scopriremo
Okay va bene
[Musica]
per 3 secondi
8€.
professore secondi oggi Eccoci qui
Madonna
c'è proprio il te li conta quei tre
secondi ma sai che sono quasi tentato di
farlo vedere che succede Cioè dovrei
spegniamo questi €8 a cazzo con i
chihuahua my boys Buongiorno ragazzi
sono in aeroporto perché oggi prendiamo
con la mano proprio iPantellas in
aeroporto sono venuti a prendere tra
l'altro per arrivare qua ho fatto un
casino quando sono atterrato per
arrivare a Tokyo ci ho messo un minuto
l'avete visto anche voi fare il
contrario ci ho messo due ore non so
come mai mi son perso c'ho le occhiaie
non esistono Vabbè ragazzi stanno per
arrivare iPantellas sono molto
emozionato perché dovrò fare io da guida
turistica se non ci stanno già un
miliardo di volte e loro neanche una
Quindi sarà molto divertente vederli
tipo incredibile Non vedo l'ora di
vedere la loro Reaction saranno stanchi
morti però insomma Adesso vediamo se
arrivano Il problema è che non avendo
internet cioè loro sono venuti qua in
aeroporto e adesso li prendo li porto a
fare il modellino WiFi per avere
Internet no Però giustamente se non
hanno il modem wi-fi non hanno internet
quindi come ci becchiamo in aeroporto
Non abbiamo calcolato questa cosa
infatti in questo momento non li sto
sentendo dovevo sentirli un'ora fa alle
8:10 sono le 9:10 Quindi ancora non ho
sentito nessuno perfetto starò qua tutta
la vita ragazzi probabilmente ragazzi
incredibile li ho trovati a caso sono lì
Sono lì adesso arrivo a casa ragazzi non
ci siamo sentiti vediamo che faccia
fanno
schifo
Mamma mia raga terrificanti 10 minuti
[Musica]
quanto me li devo tenere questi qua due
settimane e mezzo Vabbè Ercole le sue
fatiche sembra un'anima in pena Errante
il Daniel errante di Howl Allora ragazzi
mi vedete anche nel riflesso ce
l'abbiamo fatta fare la chiave
dell'albergo perché per fare una chiave
Cioè per darci la chiave dell'albergo
c'è una macchinetta automatica che ci ho
messo 16 anni alla fine io il buon J
siamo compagni Cioè non siamo nella
stessa stanza ma abbiamo praticamente un
numero di differenza quindi siamo di
fianco questo che succede giorno
Let's go ma c'è un divano Tu c'hai il
divano
ma sto male Raga ma c'è un cazzo di
divano Ma è bellissimo ma che figo è la
vista com'è No ma Ragazzi ma è pazzesca
sta roba c'è un [__] divano
ragazzi pazzesco Considerando che dovrò
passare quando due settimane mi sembra
incredibile poteva andare molto peggio
vediamo il bagno raga vediamo il bagno
Beh il bagno Forse era meglio quello
dell'altra stanza ve l'avevo detto che
sarebbe stato meglio quello dell'altra
stanza perché era troppo bella la doccia
nell'altra stanza però vabbè per essere
in Giappone Comunque l'importante è che
il cesso sia tutto automatizzato e
elettronico Beh comunque mi sono
svegliato con una bella faccia vedo vuoi
vedere quale dice hai Aspetta un attimo
Salve Forza Napoli Ecco qua Jay è uguale
alla mia identica Ma hai visto la vista
no Vediamo se ce l'hai tu
Eh come la mia Allora ragazzi siamo a
cena e abbiamo ordinato un piatto di
carne mista Cioè ha ordinato lei
praticamente che costa €8.000 va bene
cercarne di Kobe identico situazione
grazie auguri auguri grazie grazie
mettiamo la carne sopra e poi la
facciamo cuocere io non so cucinare
quindi Brucerò tutto Buon appetito
ragazzi Anzi Interactive
E vabbè ragazzi siamo tornati in albergo
e questa è la fine del primo vlog in
Giappone sono devastato sono stati
giorni pieni di jet lag Infatti vedete
sono un po' strano in sto video ma è
normale però li riprendermi perché
mentre sto registrando sono ancora in
Jet Black pieno nei prossimi giorni
comunque c'erano un sacco di altri video
ora che La combriccola si è unita niente
iscrivetevi al canale lasciate un mi
piace e noi ci vediamo very very su un
bacino Ciao